[Musique]
voici la fiche au coeur de la polémique
à gauche ça rase et mahi candidate
remplaçante aux élections
départementales dans l'hérault apparaît
voilée intolérable pour le numéro deux
du rassemblement national jordan
bardella qui partagent cette affiche sur
les réseaux sociaux
stanislas guérini aurait t'il twitté
trop vite
lundi soir sur son compte twitter le
délégué général de la république en
marche réagi à la fiche de la candidate
voilée dans l'hérault investi par la
majorité
problème le leader du parti or aux
tweets le vice président du
rassemblement national jordan bardella
les réseaux sociaux nous pousse
constamment à la faute
le miracle ce qu'il n'y ait pas plus
souvent des fautes commises exprimer ma
position personnelle c'est pas la
position qui a été retenu dans le bureau
exécutif dans marche dont acte et donc
maintenant prenons la position qui a été
adopté par le mouvement la religion n'a
pas sa place dans le débat politique n'a
pas sa place dans une campagne
électorale ne peut pas servir
d'arguments électorale c'est le candidat
tu as voulu maintenir son affichage en
faveur d'une religion ça s'appelle du
prosélytisme ça n'a pas sa place dans
une campagne et je veux saluer le
courage de style sage guérini les signes
religieux ostentatoires n'ont pas leur
place sur les affiches de campagne dans
le cadre d'une campagne électorale
c'est la ligne de notre pauvre en
politique et je crois qu'elle est
extrêmement clair donc celle de la
question de remettre ne sera pas
actionné la barre mars
je connais quelqu'un un jour seven et il
avait une chemise à manches longues mais
n'avait pas prévu le coup les caméras
qui passait par là
voici la publication partagé par le
centre lgbt de touraine à l'origine de
la polémique il est écrit que la non
mixité n'est en aucun cas négociable et
toutes personnes blanches qui essaiera
de s'incruster dans ce cortège se fera
cordialement ou non dégagées dans la
honte ou peu judiciariser là dedans
s'est caractérisée on peut normalement
traduire les dirigeants de ces
associations justice ont deux revers on
doit le faire et le maire qui
cautionnent ça les verts lâcher parce
qu'ils nous font depuis quelques mois
enfin il serait au moins eux ils se
dévoilent pour le concours 103 contre
[Applaudissements]
si tout à l'heure l'article 1er été
rejetée c'est à cause du mépris que vous
avez avec le parlement vous êtes ici
devant la représentation nationale
vous nous regarder dans les yeux et vous
arrêtez d'avoir les yeux fixés sur votre
écran
c'est compris les lieux de d'échangisme
lot de libre échangisme sont restés
ouverts durant tout le confinement de
très nombreux de nos collègues ils y
avaient leurs habitudes dans des mandats
précédents
et je ne compte même pas les ministres
parce que ça suffit maintenant on
m'avait race et du mépris de ces milices
qui viennent qui va en deux heures le
répondant aux questions qui pianote en
soit on ne sait pas qui vous avez été
mis en minorité par des membres de votre
propre majorité
vous devriez peut-être raser un peu plus
les murs la nuit dernière les
affrontements ont été particulièrement
intenses israël frappant sans répit
tandis que les groupes armés
palestiniens multipliait les tirs de
roquettes
certains ont touché tel aviv six
israéliens tués dont un enfant
tout est dit sur ce panneau écrit en
arabe nous ne partirons pas ces maisons
appartiennent à des palestiniens dans ce
quartier de jérusalem est des colons
israéliens veulent s'y installer
la justice de l'état hébreu leur a donné
raison en première instance